I could have protected them I'm a paid
officer I'm paid to protect people maybe
if I had reported he would have been
slung out the job one of David carrick's
first rape victims she's also a police
officer why didn't you report Carrick at
the time
this is one of the hardest questions
because the yeah but the culture didn't
allow me totally regret it now but at
the time
I would have been labeled as the the
woman at alleges rape no one's going to
go through the whole 30-year career with
that over the years some of PC David
carrick's crimes were reported to
several police forces but no action was
ever taken no one saw the pattern of his
behavior
the prosecutor described how Carrick met
one victim in a bar and lured her back
to his flat there he held a gun to her
head and raped her and he put his hands
around her throat and told her he'd be
the last thing she saw then he raped her
again several times
the prosecutor said the victim went to
hospital with bites bruises and bleeding
when she told a nurse she'd been raped
by a policeman the nurse advised her it
might not go to court put it behind you
and move on
at the start of the two-day hearing the
judge heard the words of several of
carrick's victims stories of betrayal
wrecked relationships and ruined lives
and much physical pain Carrick used this
whip on one victim she kept it and gave
it to police a video Carrick filmed of
his home showed the tiny cupboard in
which he locked up some victims often
for many hours
the Metropolitan Police has apologized
again for letting Carrick stay in the
force for more than 20 years undetected
I am truly sorry for the harm and
Devastation he has caused them
we let them down and we feel to identify
a man in the ranks of the Metropolitan
Police Service who carried out the most
awful offenses he should not have been a
police officer Carrick is likely to be
jailed for life with a long minimum
sentence I'd be disappointed if he
didn't get a life sentence really I'd
like to see him go down for a very long
time Carrick is expected to be sentenced
in the morning Martin brunt Sky News
Southern Crown Court